à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois jean françois kahn
qu'il publie droit dans le mur aux
éditions plon un livre sur les erreurs
en politique un sujet original un vaste
et beau sujet même pourrait-on dire
mais sur lequel il convient de
s'entendre en effet si l'on ne veut pas
les répéter ses erreurs il faudrait
savoir de quoi il s'agit exactement
c'est quoi pour vous une erreur en
politique jean françois kahn enfin pas
qu'en politique
oui c'est vrai en général oui c est ce
que la garda historiques philosophiques
non une erreur ou s'il y en a des
erreurs scientifiques
c'est le seul qu'on paye le plus c'est
quand le entamé vous esquissez une
action dans un but et que le résultat de
l'action va à l'encontre du but pour
lequel vous l'avez même que c'est
exactement le contraire le contraire
voilà par exemple le heat père
envahissant l'union soviétique il le
fait pour écraser le communisme ou et
finalement ça comme conséquence que le
communiste s'installe dans toute
l'europe de l'est hé oui les contrats
d'avenir berlin c'est le contraire de ce
pour quoi ou la libye ouais
l'intervention de la france en libye
les conséquences sont absolument
hallucinante catastrophe vie c'est à
dire vous avez déstabilisation du sahel
vous avez l'anarchie en libye vous avez
les les immigrés qui affluent à la mer
enfin tout voilà oui où l'aviation de
l'irak par les américains
alors la gare des halles et chiites qui
ont le pouvoir et l'iran qui propose
iman le camp le plus quand le pouvoir et
sa relance et le dess djce revient
d'irak
mais alors ce que quand on lit de votre
livre jean françois kahn on se dit que
les politiques qui ont fait ces erreurs
en général le paye mais les
intellectuels qui les ont inspirés eux
continuent de sévir dirais qu'il ya pas
la même il n'y a pas la même on est plus
sévère avec le politique qui réalise
l'erreur que celui qui lui a soufflé à
l'oreille
alors naturellement il ya c'est alors la
télé que tout ça dépend si c'est le
philosophe ou l'écrivain
pour ce qui est de l'écrivain c'est
parce que sa stature d'écrivains
transcende souvent l'erreur qu'il a
commise
je prends un exemple châteaubriant mais
qui le sait a été ministre des affaires
étrangères de mme élise affaires
étrangères quand même châteaubriant en
tant que les affaires étrangères il a
pris une initiative qu est l
intervention d'espagne contre une
révolution libérale qui a eu des
conséquences catastrophiques mais
absolument 80 personnes le sait personne
n'en veut parce que bon mais
chateaubriand n'est pas connu pour ça en
revanche les philosophes quelquefois
leurs erreurs c'est l'application de
leurs théories
finalement avant non on n'en veut pas au
fond le plus bel exemple moi je sais un
philosophe andré glucksmann qui est un
philosophe français n'est pas
inintéressant comme philosophe il ya des
choses intéressantes qui il a été
maillot east au début de sa vie il a été
bushiste au moment de la guerre d'irak
et en fait il s'est toujours trompé tout
le temps si vous prenez le re le court 2
de sa carrière de son existence il s'est
sûrement trompé déjà quand il était
gosse schiste il y avait une histoire
absolument incroyable sais pas si les
gens qui nous écoutent s'en souviennent
mais il y avait eu un crime hors bruay
en artois
un thriller une petite fille qui avait
été assassiné l'ailé s'était déjà été
très émue par la stasi la dune d'une
petite fille et l'extrême gauche a
décidé que là ça ça c'était l'automne le
21e terre de moins rentable ce qui a été
riche
il était riche donc c'est un assassin en
plus ils mangeaient des steaks rendez
compte un risque qu'ils mangent deux
steaks ne peut être canalsat ça et un
tueur d'enfants et ils ont fait un
procès populaire de ce mec était
totalement innocent vin c'est le bon il
y avait du chemin dans le coup et
ensuite le même glucksmann soutient la
guerre d'irak va pousser la guerre
d'irak avec un texte hallucinant dans le
monde en disant de que tony blair va
rester comme un homme considérables
comme un grand homme d'état
bush pour l'histoire sont nos rayonnera
chirac en revanche il va plonger comme
un affreux personal parce que il ne l'a
pas joints c'est formidable
et tout ça mais personne quand on parle
de glisse mal oui c'est un philosophe
intéressant mais personne ne lui en veux
personne ne lui reproche ses erreurs ça
aucune importance c'est intéressant
parce qu'entre nous ces âmes est pris en
même temps pour les intellectuels si si
vous avez un respect pour les
intellectuels un vrai respect pour leurs
pensées pour leur philosophie le moindre
des choses c'est justement de considérer
que que ce qu'ils disent est important
tout le temps est ce que vous avez fait
l'exercice sur vous-même jean françois
carré en soixante ans de journalisme au
moins vous avez dû en commettre quelques
erreurs dans dans l'ide je les fais moi
j'ai fait qu'alors scène j'ai faits
commis deux heures alors j'ai d'abord
j'ai commis une erreur ce que quand
quand il ya eu l'élection présidentielle
ou chirac a été élu contre jean marie le
pen
donc il était au deuxième tour pour la
première fois il y avait la droite et
l'extrême droite
un lâcher de la gauche est éliminé
j'étais tellement sûr que ça serait
j'ose pas chirac que pour avoir des
éditions lointaine où il fallait
avant que ça se passait a fallu boucler
rapidement j'ai fait le journal sur
jospin chirac avec des commentaires des
emballages bon c'est absolument ridicule
c'est une erreur terrible mais j'ai fait
deux erreurs
je le dis d'autant plus que je vais pas
écrit donc je pourrais ne pas le dire
que j'ai fait des erreurs mais je sais
que j'aurais pu les jo aurait pu
l'écrire et c'est intéressant parce que
c'est ça dit beaucoup sur la source de
l'erreur
la première c'est l'intervention des
russes en tchécoslovaquie donc en 68 68
j'ai longtemps pensé qu'ils
n'interviendraient pas pourquoi parce
que je vais à karlovy vary en
tchécoslovaquie et je vois brejnev qui
embrase louchet qu'il prend dans ses
bras il embrasse sur la bouche du sport
possibles vont pas intervenir ce que
c'est à dire que l'image mama mama
complètement dissimulé ce qui se cache
derrière l'image il faut toujours se
méfier de ça pour moi se méfier de
l'apparence et d'image c'est fondamental
l'autre veut l'autre cas c'est avant la
guerre des six jours j'ai assisté aux
grandes manoeuvres de l'armée égyptienne
dans le sinaï est alors des grandes
manoeuvres ses formes il a d'abord n'ya
pas d'ennemis donc c'est peinard
vous avez les chars les commandos les
troupes d'élite tu vois la soudure
c'est assez impressionnant foncé moyens
polémique en france et qui est de
foncier qu'ils avaient gagné j'ai été
très impressionné et je me suis dit bon
non je pensais qu israël allait gagner
mais je pensais me ferait très longs
comme guère d'être clos sa durée ses
jours bien sûr ça c'est très important
parce que une beaucoup d'erreurs c'est
le piège de la part belle au juste aller
au delà de la barre haut dans ce livre
vous parlez de vous expliquer que
l'extrême droite que vous appelez le
néofascisme est sur le point de gagner
l'élection présidentielle
est-ce que ça fait pas 20 ans justement
qu'on nous répète cela indéfiniment que
l'extrême droite est sur le point de
gagner l'élection présidentielle
depuis 2002 quasiment à chaque élection
on nous fait le coup est ce que est ce
que ça n'est pas une erreur qui se
répète encore une fois en parlant de la
prochaine élection présidentielle
non mais d'abord c'est la celle inverse
moi je me souviens très bien je faisais
un débat avec alain duhamel à la
télévision il ya 30 ans 40 ans et alain
duhamel et il était d'accord avec tous
les éditorialistes l'extrême droite en
france ne peut pas faire plus de 2% et
en temps de disette mais en demie à
partenord mais les rares à l'été un
verre c'est justement ils n'ont pas vu
qu'il y avait des racines de des causes
objectives qui pouvait provoquer des
phénomènes de montée de l'extrême-droite
d'autre part je vous dis je vous dis que
je parle de néo fasciste parce que pour
moi le néo fasciste c'est pas l'extrême
droite c'est une erreur considérable de
d'assimiler néofascisme extrême droite
l'extrême droite c'est quelque chose de
particulier c'est à la droite de la
droite c'est le pétainisme
c'est le sait contre révolutionnaire
c'est charles maurras et enfin que celle
le la spécificité du fascisme est
aujourd'hui du néo fasciste pour
notamment à néofasciste d'aujourd'hui
peut pas ressembler au fascisme ou
d'hier évidemment mais la spécificité de
ce que j'appelle les néofascistes c'est
la convergence extrême gauche extrême
droite
bon faut toujours le camp en 24 22 ou 23
ou 24 du souligna le congrès fascisme la
création du parti fasciste italien par
mussolini
messieurs les libyens d'extrême gauche
socialiste dans ce congrès c'est
extraordinaire faut l'étudier ce congrès
vous avez des anarcho syndicalistes
d'extrême gauche
vous avez des représentants de ce qu'on
appelait la gauche révolutionnaire et
puis vous avez des réacs en effet vous
avez des royalistes vous avez des
ultranationalistes et héros qui se sont
radicalisées pendant la guerre et c'est
cette convergence la grèce
on n'avait jamais vu ses spécificités
calé hier il ya eu en italie récemment
eu monde a cru voir sept nouveaux de
nouveau cette convergence avec
l'alliance entre le parti cinq étoiles
oui mais la ligue du nord et c'est une
saga ça a duré longtemps qu'ailleurs
séance on l'a toujours pas vu là ça peut
pas marcher parce que c'est une alliance
et qu'un parti libertaire des vidéos que
le une alliance entre une extrême droite
autoritaire et à parti libertaire c'est
totalement absurde en revanche je prends
l'exemple du coc duc au congrès
fasciste de mussolini vous avez un autre
élan ce genre en plus j'en ai parlé à
marine le pen et elle était très
intéressant il connaissait très bien
cette histoire c'est qu'on oublie
toujours un des créateurs du parti nazi
de hitler
ses deux frères qui s'appelle les frères
strasser c'est eux qui étaient les
idéologues du mouvement et les fraîches
traceur c'est des vrais socialistes
c'est à dire c'est vraiment le fascisme
ou vrai sens du terme c'est à dire à la
fois réactionnaire par certains aspects
en ti et en même temps réellement
anticapitaliste antibourgeois etc mais
simplement vous savez ce qui était
arrivé à strass r non tu vas hitler l'a
fait assassiner lors de la nuit des
longs couteaux
oui l'autre et bardi faire que ça ne
dure pas à un moment la fraction
droitière élimine l'infraction gauchy
mais à l'origine le fasciste c'est
vraiment cette convergence entre
l'extrême droite et l'extrême gauche
mais je n'ai pas l'extrême droite mais
le néofascisme aujourd'hui s'il prenait
le pouvoir en france
qu'est ce qu'il ferait que ne ferait pas
ceux qui ont eu le pouvoir depuis 20 ans
il ne voulait dire qu'il réduirait les
libertés individuelles il réduirait le
droit de manifester gilles eux ils
réduiraient la liberté d'expression mais
sait on a déjà fait ça tu ne trouves ça
normal aujourd'hui on rentre un peu tu
peux pas et puis d'autre part
c'est pour ça que ces néo ceux ci ont
dîné au il ya une raison mais pourquoi
dit-on fasciste c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui ce qui s'est passé hier
ne serait pas possible pourrait pas
faire comme comme ce qui s'est passé en
plus je vais vous dire une des raisons
pour lequel aujourd'hui quand on fait
des sondages on s'aperçoit qu'une partie
des électeurs d'extrême gauche
c'est-à-dire mélenchonistes etc
s'il y'avait macron le pen votre l opm
disent qu'ils vont très bien oui bah oui
je crois que pour 40% à 45% préféré vote
le pen alors on dit je pense que c'est
la haine de macron sajoo mais il ya une
autre raison c'est qu'il est gelée connu
moi dans ma vie de journaliste à peu
près partout il ya quand même cette idée
très forte à l'extrême gauche toujours
dans tous les pays
j'ai vu en amérique latine j'ai vu au
chili gives en argentine qui est au fond
si l'extrême droite pour le pouvoir
alors là en l'occurrence c'est l'extrême
droite où les militaires prennent le
pouvoir
c'est formidable ça va nous permettre de
nous refaire ça ne vous permettent de
pouvoir pas manifesté aux cris du
fascisme ne passera pas il ya cette idée
a mais ça marche jamais c'est pas vrai
[Musique]
est-ce que ça n'est pas une erreur de
dire qu'à chaque fois que le peu importe
comme on l'appelle le néofascisme va
prendre le pouvoir qu'il peut gagner
l'élection jeudi qu'il peut gagner
l'élection on peut gagner l'élection
présidentielle
est ce que ça ne rend pas son vote
attractif c'est à dire qu'au fond
pendant un certain temps quand on
pensait qu'il n'avait aucune chance
on savait que voter pour le front
national de jean marie le pen par
exemple ça consiste finalement à ne
voter pour rien ce qu'il n'aurait jamais
le pouvoir
à partir du moment où on lui dit b6 il
peut gagner on n'arrête pas de lui dire
ça tous les ans à chaque élection
présidentielle qui peuvent gagner la
prochaine fois non mais ça rend le lot
vote d'abord je suis pas d'accord avec
constructif ce n'est pas exact de dire
que tout le monde maintenant tout le
monde il peut griller d'abord ne disait
paradis en 2000 je sèche entre les deux
tours on sait très bien que c'était dans
tout le monde savait que c'était pas
possible ah oui mais on a là guy dans
tous les journaux
oui mais ça c'était bon c'est vraiment
maintenant concombres à saint-prosper
encore la majorité des gens ne pensent
pas ça
mais ça va dans les deux sens parce que
dire que marine le pen
d'abord moi je dis d'abord je suis le
seul à dire ses années au fascisme oui
je le dis pour la raison que je viens de
vous dire que parce que je pense qu'on
fait une erreur d'identifier néofascisme
extrême droite et que ce n'est pas
d'extrême droite je fais une parenthèse
mais on a c'est incroyable quand jean
marie le pen s'est retiré en fin de et
que sa fille a pris la succession
toute la presse en parle qui lit la
presse de gauche aly tel tel père telle
fille c'est la même chose et rien de
nouveau et ses horizons pas compris
qu'ils avaient quelque chose de
fondamentalement nouveau
fondamentalement nouveau c'est quoi
c'est que et j'en ai parlé même avec
elle c'est qu'au fond elle a compris
quelque chose c'est qu'avec deux
courants qui traversent le pignon de
courant très fort majoritaire là c'est
le rejet des dégâts du néolibéralisme
vidéo capitaliste 1 to le lean et la
justice inégalités etc et de l'autre
c'est le rejet à leur jettent des
migrations et le rejet des excès disons
sociétaux soixante huitard or jusqu'à
présent là un de ces courants s'est
porté par l'extrême gauche
la dénonciation des excès du
néocapitalisme l'autre s'est portée par
la droite
très bien clivage pro d2 c'est la
première qui dit dommage pour les deux
c'est au courant majoritaire
ça me dérange pas je prends les deux je
fusionne je peux le dire autrement et
c'est pour ça que c'est évident qu'un
parti de pas d'extrême droite mais mais
disait une certaine manière néofasciste
peut gagner les élections c'est qu'il
est potentiellement majoritaire parce
que qu'est-ce qu'il dit critique de la
bourgeoisie des des riches de défier
richard que de la société bourgeoise du
des excès du capitalisme et le
libéralisme c'est majoritaire critiques
de d2d des dysfonctionnements de l'aura
de ce qui ne marche pas dans l'europe
les l'europe normative l'europe chiante
et c'est plus la condamnation des flux
migratoires c'est majoritaire le la
dénonciation de la montée de
l'insécurité de la délinquance du crime
et ses terrasses est majoritaire et la
dénonciation comme je vous ai tout à
l'heure des excès 68 ans en matière
sociétaux etc c'est quasiment
majoritaire donc en vérité il faut bien
comprendre une chose c'était une forme
de néo fasciste qui donne pas son nom
évidemment si ce dîner aux fascistes il
ça marche mois mais aucun parti c'est
qu'au fond ils ont déjà gagné avec des
pancartes pouvoir vient d'aller aux
fascistes mais sur / en mobilisant ses
quatre créneaux la c4 créneau
potentiellement majoritaire si on ne
comprend pas ça on comprend rien et il
faut vraiment que la gauche soit aveugle
pour pas grand brahms a donc en gros ils
ont déjà gagné le pouvoir culturel
d'après vous alors ils n'ont pas que y
ait le pouvoir culturel parce que pour
le coup le monde culturel n'est pas sûr
tant les g et lyon justement ils n'ont
pas gagné sa mémé le mais ces quatre
thèmes vous dites donc vous dites qu'ils
sont engagés aujourd'hui majoritaires ça
n'était pas que genia qui sont
potentiellement sioniste anciennement je
fais encore une fois pas si vous dites
parti néo fasciste non dans l'anonymat
mais si vous dites et ça c'est l'erreur
si vous appelez parti populiste
vous imaginez voilà une erreur voilà une
erreur gigantesque énorme
vous imaginez terre que tout pour
désigner le mal hein ce qu'on considère
comme le mâle pour mobiliser contre le
mal
on le comment le qualifie comment
qualifie communiste on prend le mot où
il ya le mot peuple dans l'est mais
qu'il pouvait pas souhaiter voir il faut
pas rêver mieux
le monial mon peuple les gens ils
entendent populaire populiste ils
entendent populaire médicaux assez mal
les populaires franchement c'est mal
après andy nationaux cd nationaux
populistes à dire que moi alors je suis
patriote et paix est populaire mais
c'est très bien et c'est sans compter
que quand vous dites
mélenchon et populisme le pen et
populiste boucher populiste
chavez et populiste castro et mobile ça
veut dire quoi quand tout le monde peut
être peu plus et à mesure or cette
utilisation
paranoïaque quasiment de ce mot
populiste pour désigner tout ce dont on
veut pas mais ça a été une erreur mais
j'y compte s elle est la preuve la
preuve c'est que c'était disqualifiant
normalement on l'avait pour disqualifier
mais aujourd'hui serait que là il dit il
nous sommes populaires ils ont compris
alors justement l'une des questions que
vous posez dans ce livre la question
principale c'est comment en est on
arrivé là
finalement et parmi les et vous lister
un peu de toutes les erreurs que non
seulement ont été commises mais qui ont
été répétés parce qu'on ne veut pas les
reconnaître donc on les répète ces
erreurs là elle a la taille de la russie
est un bon exemple
laquelle ben napoléon a fait cette
erreur et d hitler l'a répété répété de
la meinau ce fait on se fait bananer au
vietnam les américains répondent on
reconnaît pas que c'est une erreur d
american art et pen et alors vous vous
revenez sur le référendum de maastricht
vous dites que là il ya vraiment le
divorce entre les médias les grands
médias à l'époque
enfin à l'époque y a que des grands
médias qui sont à 90% en faveur du oui à
maastricht et de la population puisque
plus de la moitié des électeurs vont
voter pour le non et au fond j'ai
l'impression que c'est là vous voyez
démarrer un problème qui est cette
espèce de propagande unilatéral c'est
vous qui ont vous payez ce terme qui
naît à partir de maastricht tout à coup
et vous êtes vous avez dont vous avez
parlé dans un livre est paru il ya
quelques années qui est l horreur
médiatique d'ailleurs ça ça continue
aujourd'hui
oui j'ai fait un livre qui s'appelait la
pensée unique j'ai l'entrée une course
simple à terre c'est vrai nom là moi
j'ai voté oui
donc c'est pas comme on dirait c'est pas
parce que je suis pas content d'avoir
perdu en l'occurrence j'ai voté oui mais
c'était évident ici de parler
les gens autour de soi qu'il y avait des
gens qui étaient pour le nom bon et dans
la presse non c'est à dire tous les 95%
des journaux écrits habdomadaire
quotidiens radios télés et cetera était
en faveur du oui et même si moi même
j'ai voté oui c'est inconcevable c'était
pas possible qu'il ya un tel décalage
entre ce que la pluralité de l'opinion
et cette espèce d'unicité de
l'expression de ce qui était censé
refléter le bio que c'était inconcevable
l'action vote 54 % pour le non
alors que 95% des médias papa les
réseaux sociaux des quinquas était pour
lui et à ce moment là
moi j'ai téléphoné aux médias radio
télévision etc pour leur dire attendez
vous c'est très important
l'ensemble du corps médiatique 95% des
mia tout toutes tendances et toutes
formes confondues ont milité pour le oui
et 55 % ont voté pour n'aurait jamais vu
de tels cas sur entre l'opinion les
médias c'est un vrai problème pour y
réfléchir
il faudrait peut-être examiner ça
voudrait faire des débats et ses refus
total ya pas une ruine au mieux deux
temps il n'y a pas eu une seule radio
une seule télé que terra qui ont accepté
qu'on puisse faire un débat à une
rencontre une confrontation sur ce
problème essentiel qu'on paye très cher
ça m'est arrivé une deuxième fois je
fais une parenthèse c'est sûr moment de
la guerre en libye
quand on a décidé la guerre en libye
tout le monde parce que la gauche a voté
pour et la droite était pour donc moi je
pensais que ça allait être
catastrophique pareil je téléphone au
mot radio ou télé lesquelles mme ma vie
de sans arrêt pour parler de n'importe
quoi le prix des carottes et ces mesures
dit non j'ai rien à dire mais alors là
je si vous voulez je voudrais vous dire
pourquoi on n'entend pas ça sur votre
antenne tout le monde et pour pourquoi
ça peut être catastrophique
rien dans ce soir ou jamais j'ai fait de
ma personne
personne même amendement accepté que
j'aille et expliquer ça je sentais
qu'elle pour ça que ces gens j'en garde
un souvenir donc au moment donc il y
avait cette cassure au moment du
référendum
mais là où la cerise sur le gâteau c'est
que finalement fait passer par le vote
du parlement qu'ils avaient la majorité
le projet européen
c'est pas tout à fait le même et pour
les gens c'est elle opère dix vols sans
consulter le peuple puisque le peuple
avait refusé mais vous y même encore je
peux pas aller à un endroit sans qu'on
m'en parle mais c'est ça la démocratie
on piétine notre l'expression qu'on a
exprimé que ça mais ça fait un mal
absolument incroyable on n'imagine pas
le mal que ça avait mais c'est
l'unanimisme qui fait du mal le fait que
les contestataires tous ceux qui sont
hors normes sont considérés comme des
populistes comme des fascistes et sont
pour ainsi dire exclu du jeu non ça
c'est pas tout à fait exact je sais
c'est un peu ce que vous laissez
entendre d'autres non parce que je vous
signale ça va pas du tout dans votre
sens que les gilets jaunes qui se
présentait comme les révoltés et cetera
royaume tous les médias pour eux pendant
très longtemps
il ya la façon qu'ils avaient puisqu'il
regardez il ya une vague regarder sur
les radios on continue on n'avait jamais
vu ça
jamais vous aviez déjà vu à la
télévision du matin au soir
du matin au soir d'abord des
manifestations de gilet jaune
ouais en direct pendant toute la journée
jamais j'ai vu ça ouais j'aime
participer à des manifestations d'été un
million un million et demi de millions
ça faisait dix minutes-là gens pensent
que ça vous même quand ils étaient 60
même quand il était va sûrement essayer
avec eux ça la série lance et tous les
débats ou des chaînes d'info continue
fabien caire montre quelques jeunes et
dans tous les débats où j'ai été pendant
encore quelques mois
partout il veut gilet jaune en face la
cérémonie au fax 01 le verre ou deux
mais bon donc on peut pas dire leur là
remonde je dirais clients un phénomène
d'unanimisme condamnable mais
l'unanimisme la a été plutôt favorable
gilet jaune jeudi que faut pas dire ça
mais vous dites qu'on a fait cadeau du
peuple l extrême droite
dans votre livre est ce qu'on n'a pas
cru a fait on a fait cadeau du peuple ah
oui l'extrême droite est-ce qu'on
n'attaque pas fait cadeau des villes et
jaune à l'extrême droite aussi en leur
reprochant d'être des factieux d'être
antisémite d'être homophobe
etc etc est ce que tu te bats pas une
manière de les jeter de les précipiter
dans les bras de l'extrême droite lors
merron iliad et c'est le gouvernement
qui a essayé de faire mais c'est pas
dans l'ensemble les médias mais en plus
en plus extra nerfs parce que je vois
par exemple le type le plus à droite de
tous les journalistes du figaro ivan
rioufol est un fanatique des gilet jaune
et le mec le plus à gauche de tous les
gens lisent de marianne est un fanatique
de gilet jaune ya aussi ce phénomène
mais j'espère quand même qu'on appelle
qu'on avait absolument jamais vu et
entre nous il ya cette convergence
une des raisons pour laquelle j'étais
réticent
par rapport au gilet jaune cc c'est
qu'on voyait cette convergence la dent
dont pas entre nous vous dites que vous
avez là en fait les gilets jaunes
auraient eu comment la pensée unique
contre eux alors que moi je vous dis il
ya eu il ya une pente et unique jeu
prochains jo je vous donne un exemple
personnel
il ya eu 12 livres qui sont parues
jusqu'à présent absolument enthousiastes
projet les jaunes mais comment je le
sais parce que j'ai écouté à france
inter à france culture il était invité
et c'est moi chez le premier livre qui
est critique vis-à-vis du gilet jaune
s'est invitée nul c'est radio
ben c'est quand même un bon c'est ta vie
tes i7 quand un bon exemple
et en plus parce qu'il faut qu'on mette
jeu est belle je le dis devant vous
parce que vous pour vous pouvez me
confortez 6 à quelqu'un qui a eu des
raisons d'être projet les jaunes c'est
moi bah moi entend donc quand je
dirigeais marianne et tout ce qu'on a
dit dans marianne est quasi fois
quelquefois seul des quelques fois en en
prenant plein la gueule
c'est vraiment ce que les jets les
jaunes ont essayé de porter y compris ce
que vous avez écrit contre francs contre
l'élection de françois hollande dans
votre livre la catastrophe les cimaises
de sueur sur ce qu'on a dit sur le
référendum la sueur constitutionnel et
quand même et son horreur médiatique
jura sur leurs heures médiatique sur un
système électoral qui fait qu'avec 24 %
d'aidés des voix on a 60 % des députés
sur le cic eux surtout surtout le
problème il suffit pas de dire ah mais
tout ça je les dis bon moi j'ai été voir
j'ai été sur les rangs point j'étais
dans les manifs ont pu vous savez où
j'habite
j'avais place de la république lui alors
franchement aaa
c'est en permanence et bon bah je sais
que ça va pas plaire ce que je dis mais
mais j'ai été effaré souvent pas parce
que j'ai vu et entendu je ne croyais pas
que je me sens sûr mais c'est le moment
où on fait une pause on se retrouve
juste après avec jean françois kahn
[Musique]
est ce qu'on peut parler de fracture
entre le nord de l'europe et le sud
on sait qu'il ya une fracture on sait
qu'il ya des pays qui ont été mal géré
vous avez deux pays de la zone euro et
donc les pays du sud qui n'ont pas
encore retrouvé leur niveau de richesse
d'avant la crise vous avez la grèce et
aussi lit-on malgré tout les aides qu'on
a pu avoir au niveau de nouvelles de
l'euro n'a pas réussi à sortir de la
crise c'est à dire qu'on parle de la
baisse du chômage au portugal ou en
espagne
en fait c'est simplement que vous avez
une grosse partie de la population et
des jeunes sont partis le drame c'est
que tous ces pays amis notamment chez
nous en france des publics a augmenté
mais n'a pas généré de croissance est
lente
je ne sais pas qui est la locomotive de
l'europe en tout cas ne croyez pas que
ce soit la france
[Musique]
mais
l'europe la france aujourd'hui on a du
mal à comprendre ce qui s'y passe les
chiffres sont bons
personne n'est content c'est à dire que
la désindustrialisation de la france
très très fort depuis 20 ans s'est
traduite par des fermeture de milliers
d'usinés
peu de gens osent le dire mais je le dis
il ya un retour en allemagne depuis une
dizaine d'années d'un mépris pour la
france parce que les allemands n'ont pas
compris qu'un pays adultes se laissent
des industrialisés comme nous l'avons
fait et ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi
depuis 50 ans on est en déficit que la
conjoncture soit bonne ou mauvaise
devant encore vous dire que vous vous
comparer à l'allemagne je ne rentre pas
dans cette approche des gens qui
sous-estiment l'allemagne et l'allemagne
est en fait tant son insertion dans
l'économie mondiale dans la même
position que le japon donc l'allemagne
n'est pas foutu est donc la clé serbe
pourrait être l'entente entre la france
et l allemand la question reste sur la
table dans la mesure où ça fait dix ans
que les allemands bloque tout l'initiale
historique
[Musique]
on poursuit cette émission avec jean
françois kahn qui vient de publier droit
dans le mur aux éditions plon un livre
sur les erreurs et en particulier sur
les erreurs en politique en tout cas
c'est sous cet aspect là que j'avais
envie de vous interviewez jean françois
kahn il ya les erreurs ce qu'on appelle
l' impérialisme vous parliez d'un jeu de
rêve offert une petite remarque rien
faire un petit robert veut pas une
remarque à propos des gilet jaune
ouais c'est que marine le pen a les
raisons soutenir les gilet jaune en a
profité à tout point de vue je pense que
j'aurais été à sa place j'aurais fait
comme elle mais mélenchon s'est
complètement investie totalement
identifié au gilet jaune qui a appelé à
aller au gel et jaune
il était à 20% il s'est retrouvé à six
quant à l'issue d'une bataille alors
comparé à 20% on se retrouve à six
ben voilà c'est le l'exemple même de 2,2
du résultat qui tournent et tournent
habituellement le dos à ce pourquoi on
avait esquissé cette wii c'est
l'orientation générale c'est la
définition même de l'erreur quelle
erreur
alors justement je voulais en parler de
deux des erreurs de ce que vous appelez
l'impérialisme vous citiez la libye tout
à l'heure avant la libye avait eu la
passion de l'irak par les américains on
l'a dit keith qui a obtenu le résultat
exactement inverse puisque les chiites
ont pris le pouvoir
ensuite ça a profité à l'iran puis
ensuite c'est dèche qui est arrivé or à
chaque fois on ne tient pas compte on ne
veut pas reconnaître l'erreur donc là
réitère quand françois hollande veut
intervenir en syrie
à votre avis il commet il aurait commis
la même erreur que george bush en
intervenant en irak
et si oui est-ce qu'on intervenant au
sel comme il l'a fait encore aujourd'hui
les français sont au sel
est ce que c'est la même dans les pays
du sahel dans les pays du sahel bien
entendu est ce que c'est la même erreur
c'est un peu différent parce que c'est
pas des interventions massives en plus
et là c'est des interventions la demande
des gouvernements
ça veut pas dire que je suis favorable
vu passer une erreur mais enfin c'est on
peut pas tout à fait comparer mais le
fait qu'on ne recommence joue signale
que cette erreur là la plus bel exemple
de ce type d'erreurs c'est napoléon en
espagne on apprenait on intervient en
espagne il est convaincu qu'il va être
tu va provoquer l'enthousiaste de la
population c'est un régime absolument
réactionnaire c'est un régime
complètement pourri avec l'inquisition
féodal de il décide d'abolir
l'acquisition de d'abolir le servage et
séries vont se ça va être formidable
dans le les mecs se saouler mais contre
lui quand même les de gauche à droite
soulève contre lui c'était une leçon
formidable
le fait qu'on ait recommencé constamment
cette opération parce que ces revers
toujours la même opération en croyant
toujours que les populations
bush qui est convaincu que les irakiens
vont l'encenser on est convaincu que les
libyens vont nous en france et on
recommence toujours c'est ça qui est
incroyable c'est le recommencement la
capacité de le voir mais alors il ya une
erreur qui expliquerait pour quelles
raisons
ce que vous appelez le néofascisme
pourrait remporter les élections
présidentielles on le dit et vous vous
le citez dans votre livre le refus par
l'immigration qui a été dur et longtemps
le refus par la sécurité ça a été aussi
un problème
le refus de parler de lalaye de remettre
en cause la laïcité également voir de
l'islam ou de reprendre le drapeau
français
tout ça ça aurait été moi je sais pas ce
que j'ai mis un drapeau dans le type de
marianne quand j'ai créé marianne je
vous dis pas ce que j'ai entendu à vous
faites un journal fasciste parce qu'il
ya le drapeau tricolore
mais à déserter qui dans le pommeau cela
depuis les hommes politiques au pouvoir
lanta prix aussi bien nicolas sarkozy
pourrait ne rien dire manuel valls 3
pour français jean michel blanquer
aujourd'hui qui veulent mettre dans les
dents lait dans les écoles
emmanuel macron qui nous parle
aujourd'hui de l'islam en temps de jeu
c'est bon français le drapeau français
sait c'est une minorité gauche radicale
et ses parfums la sécurit mais l'islam
mais je vais vous donner un exemple il
ya trois valeurs passées n'étaient pas
les seuls mais il ya trois valeurs que
conques la gauche républicaine ont pas
apporté la gauche vraiment c'est quoi
d'abord la patrie on appelait ça les
patriots en 89 et là vraiment les
patriotes à dire contre l'est contre la
droite sans patrie contre la droite du
capital et de l'argent nous on allait
des pieds enracinés dans le terroir
c'est la patrie c'est le travail
c'est vraiment le contre les nobles
qu'ils me foutent rien et était en des
pensions nous on est le parti du travail
et la famille les allocations familiales
on milite contre pour contre l'effet que
les enfants aillent dans les mines à
l'âge de 8 ans qui aidera donc vraiment
ces trois valeurs qui ont porté la
dynamique de la gauche républicaine là
dessus arrivé au pouvoir avec le
maréchal pétain donc le régime de vichy
qui parce que qui trahi et la patrie qui
divisent qui aliène de travail qui
exploite le travail et qui divise les
familles
ouais mais comme il veut supprimer être
liberté égalité fraternité
il prend ça parle famille patrie famille
travail la gauche républicaine les
républicains des démocrates auraient dû
attendait c'est une escroquerie
ça vole vous nous avez volé ça on vous
le reprend c'est un scandale c'est pas
vous vous au contraire vous vous allez
vous allez à l'encontre de toutes ces
valeurs vous piétinez ses malheurs on
vous le reprend et qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait ah bon vous les laisse que nous les
avait pris on aime vous prenez mon
portefeuille a pour moi c'est à vous
méfier jeu je vous en fais cadeau et
après on a continué quand les camps
l'extrême rasd a commencé à dire nation
ah bon vous avez dit nation donc ça vous
appartient elle a dit patrick ali patron
bombe à se battre ici
après dix laïcité allez vous dites
réciter alors on aurait pu dire que
c'est eux
les mêmes laïcité qui manifestent contre
tout
le pm and is it est un monument voulait
faire il suffit que l'extrême droite où
je suppose et l'extrême droite
mettre son doigt sur une valeur sûre
c'est à vous j'avais touché
on y touche passé avoue thomas c'est le
truc le plus dingue qu'on puisse
imaginer donc peuvent tous mais passée
la patrie la nation etc
il reste quoi bref c'est assez voici
peut-être l'erreur des erreurs c'est
quand même ou su cela est ce que la
social démocratie elle aussi elle a
renoncé à beaucoup de choses
vous lui si on en est arrivé là
aujourd'hui c'est aussi la foudre des
sociaux démocrates
ben parce que la social démocratie
comment s'est créé la social démocratie
elle s'est créée à partir de 1920 la
saision que les socialistes entre les
communistes et les socialistes alors les
communistes se sont ralliés à la
dictature bolchevique
mais les sociaux démocrates faut dire
qu'il portait un lourd fardeau parce que
derrière jaurès il s'était opposé à la
guerre et dire on fera la guerre je
ferai la grève générale mobilisation des
peuples pour empêcher ce carnage et non
seulement ils n'ont pas fait grève
générale non seulement il se pend
mobilisés mais ils ont participé au
gouvernement d'union nationale pour
faire la guerre et pousser à la guerre
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui a pesé
sur la social démocratie mais on sait
aussi que la social-démocratie pente ou
20e siècle ça représentait quelque chose
c'était une façon de tempérer de limiter
les effets du marché et du capitalisme
surtout du marché à la limite la social
démocratie pouvait accepter le
capitalisme mais elle circonscrit mais
le les zones que le marché pouvait
populations de l'est mokrane conduit sa
des pulkas la social-démocratie à porter
sans doute c'est sans doute le coran qu
apporter le plus à la société
d'aujourd'hui de la contribué à
l'humanisation du capitaliste là elle a
contribué à un certain nombre de progrès
sociétaux économiques sociaux c'est
absolument incontestable avec simplement
le double langage le fait que sa
pratique ne correspondait pas totalement
à son langage jusqu'au bout la pratique
était un anti capitalisme effréné et
l'ap raté hélas le discours la pratique
été réformé ce bon mais elle a apporté
beaucoup de choses ce qui s'est passé en
partie y est pour la france c'est que
ses opposants
les opposants lui reprocher son arc 1
quand il ya eu la vague néolibérale son
arc he is en disant ouais vous êtes vous
resté attaché des vieilles lunes le
socialisme l'étatisme et qui devra
regarder quand même le match des marchés
déchaînés se passe quelque chose une
dynamique sachant sa boule verte etc
vous n'êtes pas moderne et claira et et
à la fin ils ont été que complètement
stressée par sa wii on n'est pas moderne
etc et tout à coup ils ont décidé d'être
moderne dont ils ont décidé modernes ils
sont ralliés peu à peu au néolibéralisme
est pas ça correspondu à la crise'
néolibéralisme résoudre la crise de 2008
et au moment où tout à coup il ya rejet
en effet de deux des terribles des excès
des dernières c'est ça qu'ils se sont
ralliés au moment où s'étaient rejeté
mais est-ce que si on doit faire le
compte des erreurs politiques
c est ce que à chaque fois le fait qu'
il faisait la même politique économique
qu'ils soient de droite ou de gauche
quand il arrive au gouvernement en
france tout simplement parce qu'on peut
plus avoir en france une politique
économique indépendante qu'il faut le
reconnaître et l'accepter si du moins si
l'on est européen moi je croire à chaque
fois ils disent la même chose je vais
les renégocier des critères européens
etc des traités enfin toute façon vu ça
c'est pas vrai heureusement ils savent
que ce n'est pas vrai donc pourquoi le
dire mais en revendre doivent bien sûr
non mais ça se bat hollande a dit les
renégocier avec merkel ben c'est la
phrase c'est quand même le plus bel
exemple
mais j'espère l'avait dit aussi oui mais
les baisser la phrase 2e
de hollande hollande on oublie toujours
quand il ya eu les élections
présidentielles que six mois avant six
mois à vendre déjà je trouve qu'elle
était à 3 62% les sondages je mettais à
62% strauss kahn
et en plus quand hollande a pris la
place pour les raisons que vous savez de
strauss kahn
les premiers sondages j'ai été à 60% 62
% et + la campagne avançait plus besset
puis besset pluie mais c'est un moment
c'était ric rac rally 10/10 ses proches
mal quand ces fonds ont trouvé un truc
c'est pas possible ça s'apprend page
apprîmes pas comme on dit maintenant et
le type fut écrit sa fameuse phrase mon
ennemi c'est la finance
et alors il me la passe pas un mot ou
s'il ya quelque chose que hollande ne
pense pas c'est vraiment que la finance
est un ennemi un pas du tout il le dit
il le dit en effet ça remonte un peu et
en fait c'est son drame
c'est à dire que jamais en vérité pour
les jo comme cela n'imprime pas ce qu'il
disait
comme on ne retenait pas qu'est ce que
les gens retenus ils n'ont retenu que ça
que ça naturellement il a fait la
politique de la finance n'a pas né n'a
pas fait il ne s'est pas opposé à la
finance donc été foutu partir de
formules a été foutu mais de la même
manière au fond que ce soit la droite ou
la gauche est ce qu'il ya une véritable
différence en tout cas dans les
gouvernements commencent et de l'accès
des c'est de la blague c'est à dire
c'est les gouvernements qui pousse à des
avances pour dire l'europe
nous empêche la bureaucratie de ces lois
nous empêche de la mondialisation nous
empêche c c'est une façon de se
camoufler et d'expliquer pourquoi ils ne
font rien qui font le contraire de ce
sur quoi ils ont été élus et
l'agressivité envers l'europe
d'abord je vais dans votre sens si
vraiment il pensa faut qu'ils arrêtent
de faire les promesses qu'il faut c'est
pas qu'on se batte s'ils pensent ça mais
en fait non c'est on peut faire des
choses que considérable savons il songe
pas bien sûr qu'on peut le faire alors
de la même manière je vous posais la
question finalement moi j'aime pas or
ban pour des tas de raisons
urban c'est une politique économique
pratiquement socialisante par certains
côtés tati ce qui va à l'encontre total
de la pratique libérale classique
je vous disais tout à l'heure si en fait
si demain arrivait au pouvoir en france
des néo fascistes comme vous les appelez
qu'est ce qu'ils feraient que nous ne
faisons pas ça reste pour moi une grande
occasion parce qu'il ferait on passe est
il différent ils feraient pas et ferais
il ferait pas parce que c'est plus
possible c'est pour la continuer c'est
vrai pur bottes avec des avec des
uniformes alors d'abord de mussolini n'a
jamais dit dans son programme qu'il
allait installer une dictature si vous
avez la partie de son programme et on
oublie toujours hitler quand et je veux
pas du tout la comparaison serait
absurde et odieux mais quand il perd
gagne 1 44% des voix 49 49 accord il a
fait 44 % mais il y il avait baissé
quand il arrivait au pouvoir il fait
dans le premier gouvernement qu'il qu'il
que thil dans son premier gouvernement
ben il ya deux ministres l'asie tous les
autres c'est la droite conservatrice la
droite libérale et caetera et dissout
pas les parties il le fait très vite
après mais c'est jamais dans leur
programme
alors je veux pas dire par là que si
marine le pen était au pouvoir elle
appliquerait la dictature je pense que
c'est pas possible
en revanche je elle ferait un certain
nombre de choses qui fait que
contrairement à ce que l'extrême gauche
croit ça serait populaire
mais ralph rennes elle ferait réellement
une politique anti immigration
extrêmement dur extrêmement dur elle
ferait une politique sécuritaire
extrêmement dur peut-être qu'au bout de
plusieurs années après on le paye très
cher mais sur le moment on l'a bien vu
en italie ou bien vers l'italie sur le
moment évidemment ça concerne le rsa sa
base électorale est ce que depuis un
certain nombre d'années déjà et on
réduit les libertés individuelles dans
un pays comme la france
est-ce que ça fait partie des erreurs
politiques que l'on répèterai dans le
sens où en faisant cela on prépare la
population à accepter le fait que par
nécessité parfois il faut bien réduire
les libertés individuelles ça ne
choquera - le joueront les réduira
drastiquement puisqu'on les a rogné
petit à petit plus un rond peuvent on
peut pas déroger
on peut pas dire aujourd'hui qu'en
france on réduit considérablement les
normes certains considérablement on les
a réduit petit à petit un peu tout le
temps où price vous ne parlez pas pas il
s'agirait vous je crois qu'il faut pas
exagérer sur la la réduction des
libertés individuelles non je crois que
quoi il ya beaucoup de problèmes
vraiment c'est pas le jeu
d'ailleurs si vous interrogez les gens
notre impression c'est plutôt le laxisme
individus auraient plutôt tendance à
dire qui en a trop françois sureau par
exemple dans ses livres de cesse de
dénoncer j'ai lu son livre c'est pas
convaincant vous n'êtes pas convaincu
parce que là c'est une espèce de comment
un peu logomachie d'avocats
d'or pour un avocat ont réduit toujours
la liberté la foire des visio et le fait
de condé réduit la liberté d'expression
aussi c'est ce que disent aussi et les
avocats et pas seulement les attendait
ce faux pas dire sam walsh et j'ai
justement j'ai un âge très avancé je
suis né sous clemenceau comme vous le
savez et j'ai été journaliste au début
des années 60 dans plusieurs journaux
vous imaginez parce que c'était moi je
vais vous dire il ya eu une
manifestation pour ce une manifestation
qui s'appelait la monétisation de sharon
nous dire une manifestation contre l'oas
en france à une grande manifestation
contre l'oas
la police est intervenue à une foire
morts les gens disaient pas on est en
dictature celle fasciste l'a9 marquant
même agression extrêmement gpal j'y
étais j'ai découvert cette manifestation
qui était extrêmement pacifique
pacifique 9 noir très bien le lendemain
matin j'arrive au journal dans lequel je
travaillais et quand même j'avais vécu
quelque chose de violent
j'attendais qu'on me demande de faire
l'arctique est ce que je vais avoir une
demi-page un quart de page un t shirt
blanc on me demandait rien donc je
m'approche du directeur de la rédaction
qui était au téléphone et tout à coup je
comprends qu il au téléphone avec le
ministère de l'intérieur qui lui dicte
le récit de la manifestation a rejoint
on ne demande rien et on va publier le
récit de la monétisation de mr
d'intérieur serait qu'on se va un petit
peu avant 61 il y avait une
manifestation d'algériens contre le
couvre feu il ya eu combien on saura
jamais 50 morts 60 morts qu'on a
retrouvé pendu dans les bois etc
je laisse eu on m'a montré les photos
les cagoles un photographe les poteaux
moi vous dire que je n'ai on n'a pas pu
mais je n'ai même pas pu faire en sorte
qu est de l'île là dessus les gens de
gens ça c'est pas très cher convaincu je
pense effectivement que soul général de
gaulle on est dans une démocratie qu'on
qualifierait aujourd'hui ça se
réintéresse tpir avancer la démocratie
autoritaire c'est comme ça qu'on
l'appellerait aujourd'hui mes nerfs mois
après il ya eu la gauche et mitterrand
et puis tout s'est semble-t-il d'après
ce qu'ont
toujours dit tout s'est ouverte où s'est
libéralisé même déjà tous de soulever
les giscard d'estaing qui de plus en
plus ensuite on dit par ailleurs qu'
aujourd'hui ce serait l'inversé c'est à
dire qu'on voit de plus en plus -
liberté d'expression mois le droit de
manifester etc etc alors magnifique posé
je me posais la question de savoir si si
vous étiez d'accord avec ces dames et
dire qu'à moins de ne le dis pas il ya
moins droit de manifester hommage vous
aime je vous ai dit j'ai appelé place de
la république
faut pas me dire ça à moi en train de
charger j'ai même eu une fois trois
manifestations dans la journée dont une
manifestation de sûr mais c'est la seule
qui faisait pas de bruit mais alors je
pourrais vous dire et c'est la question
qu'on peut se poser à partir du moment
où le préfet a le droit d'interdire à
tel ou tel de manifester il ya une
réduction mais il ya toujours et les
interdictions ont toujours existé avatar
dgt dans le nombre de manifestations
auxquelles j'ai assisté ou que ces
principes et qui étaient interdites et
je peux vous dire que c'était réprimer
interdire une manifestation c'est normal
on peut le dire partout pour troubles de
l'ordre public mais interdire à jean
françois kahn de manifester ça c'est
nouveau mais là oui ça c'est monsieur
mais par exemple le
ils ont interdit de manifester sur les
champs elysées mais avant d'interdire à
manille visées sur les champs elysées il
ya eu les manifestants seraient janvier
qui ont mal tourné
moi quand quand j'étais quand j'avais 50
ans ils ont expérience était même
inconcevable de rester sur le pouvoir a
toujours eu le droit de vous dire vous
pouvez le manifester ici et pas là tel
joue à vendre si vous n'aviez pas
république nation voilà
ou alors si on avait on avait le droit
d'être sur les champs elysées si on
était des droits parce qu'en plus c'est
incroyable la droite un drôle je disais
la gauche
la question que je me pose c'est elle
est d'ailleurs le bon côté des gilets
jaunes c'est que pour une fois on a une
éducation contestataires et avec des
gauchistes pas pu aller sur les champs
elysées mais voilà que je me pose c'est
est ce que ce ne sont pas des erreurs
là où vraiment au sens où vous
l'entendez c'est à dire ça va provoquer
l'effet inverse de ce qu on pourrait de
ce qu'on pouvait espérer
quand on voit par exemple jérôme
rodriguez un des leaders des gilets
jaunes
enfin des parts parole des villes et
jaume arrêté hier à lille alors qu'il
est en train de déjeuner au restaurant
est-ce que ça ça fait pas partie des
erreurs pourquoi faire ce genre de
choses au même moment un autre ancien
porte parole des jeunes eric drew et
arrêtez enfin évacué au salon de
l'agriculture
est-ce que ça ça fait pas partie des
erreurs que vous dénoncez parce que
répéter les unes derrière les autres au
fond ce que ça donne des voix au héros à
l'opposition ou pire encore sa savonne
la planche sur laquelle un jour ou
l'autre un néo fascisme
non c'est bien s'installer c'est pas des
erreurs c'est des conneries c'est
différent une erreur il faut il ya une
différence entre une faute une erreur et
une connerie moi par exemple un jour
j'ai dit un truc qu'on m'a beaucoup
reproché avec raison d'ailleurs j'ai
reconnu pourquoi vous faites allusion à
propos de cruscades
mais une phrase qu'on m'a beaucoup
reproché c'était pas une erreur c'était
une connerie c'est différent c'est pas
une erreur parce qu'en vérité que je
trouve khan considéré que c'était
lüthi nage domestique c'est comme ça
qu'il le considérait donc quand je les
dis c'était pas une erreur mais c'était
une connerie
le dire comme ça il ya une vie et ça
c'est des conneries c'est pas des
erreurs mais une connerie aussi on peut
la payer
oui quand on refait l'histoire de live
les chansons françaises on me dit moment
on fait la part des fautes et des
erreurs juste des fous alors c'est une
pure erreur comme les fautes c'est par
exemple le camp
la politique antisémite d'hitler c'est
une faute c'est une faute énorme mais
c'est pas une erreur puisque c'est ce
qu'il veut faire
oui ce qui correspond à son objectif
d'une faute morale ça dépasse d'une
erreur de sa vie
c'est horrible de dire ça mais il ya
d'équations entre la la la la
le but est le résultat c'est
malheureusement une erreur mais c'est
une faute
inouï qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait jean
françois kahn pour inverser le cours de
l'histoire qui vous semble un peu
inexorable aujourd'hui je n'ai pas dit
que je crois pas du tout que le cours de
l'histoire inexorable jeu sans quoi je
rentrerai chez moi je ferais publie donc
je crois qu'on peut on peut se battre on
peut changer les choses c'est vrai il
faut toujours se battre
c'est pas facile moi j'étais j'étais
très étonné j'étais récemment contre les
pesanteurs je parle dans mon lit pendant
d'erreurs historiques qu'on est
indulgent vis-à-vis les graves erreurs
historiques
j'ai été très frappée d'apprendre c'est
il ya quinze jours quand enrichi quand
on fait des sondages sur les personnages
historiques les plus populaires c'est à
lille est remonté très très haut on vous
dit qu'il est remonté à 60 % d'opinions
favorables
donc vous dire ça quand même pas croyab
staline 60% d'opinions favorables avec
le goulag les millions de morts
la tyrannie mais nous qui sait les deux
personnages qui arrive en tête quand on
fait un sondage sur les personnages les
plus populaires
les deux plus grands tyrans est ce qu'on
fera vous exagérez 1e général de gaulle
qui arrive en général
avant d'apposer historique louis xiv non
mais n'a n'a alors plus anciens vous
délasser c'est valable dans l'histoire
c'est napoléon et louis xiv
c'est vers l'est des plus grands tyrans
de l'histoire de france et napoléon qui
a fait des millions de gens est
d'ailleurs louis xiv aussi avec des
guerres continuer et c'est eux qui sont
antenne donc voyez c'est pas bien il ya
des faux ce que c'est contre cette
maison que sa place et c'est l'idée
qu'on se batte sur tous ces directions
noir sur l'agresseur sur le se battent
par exemple aujourd'hui contre une
injustice est nécessaire mais aussi se
battre contre le fait que qu'on peut
mythifié à un homme comme louis xiv qui
était un tyran
et qui affaiblit la france caroline et
la france c'est important si ça fait
partie de tous les combats des
mystificateurs qui sont nécé quant au
lait quand on lit votre livre
droit dans le mur on se dit au fond on a
le choix entre soit hérité d'un pouvoir
néofasciste à la prochaine élection
présidentielle soit réélire tout ce que
vous a accusé d'avoir commis des erreurs
et de les répéter à l'infini qui a pas d
autres alternatives j'accuse soit la
légende avoir fait des erreurs je
considère qu'on ne peut pas que je vous
ai moi même j'en ai commis comme je
voulais dire c'est de ne pas admettre
l'erreur de ne pas la regarder en face
et donc d'être en situation de la
répéter donc grosso modo la gauche de
gouvernement ou la droite de
gouvernement vont répéter les uns et des
autres c'est quand même extraordinaire
vous aviez le parti je prends l'exemple
du parti socialise quand il s'est hissé
au pouvoir une halle président il a le
parlement il a les députés il a des
départements et la dérision 2012 en 2012
oui il a tout il a tout c'est lui qui a
le plus d'argent parce que comme c'est
le groupe majoritaire au parlement cvca
le plus d'argent
il présente un candidat mecs et 6%
si donc 2017 par daury silence non mais
vous rendez qu il est parti socialiste
depuis h et crds et demi le parti
socialiste est un grand pas oui s'ils se
ressemblent il sortait de cinq ans de
pouvoir ce que vous avez à moi ça fait
rien le les gaullistes pas tombées à 6%
après trente ans de 40 ans de pouvoir
ni poutine avec son parti ni aucun ces
bons 6%
le mec qui fait 6 % après benoît hamon
est ce que il faut une réunion pendant
une semaine duquel erreurs on a commis
absolument pas il n'y a pas un seul
moment où ces gens se mettent ensemble
pour dire qu'elle est rare qu'on aurait
pour faire 6 %
non seulement ça mais ils sont d'une
arrogance terrible c'est eux qui donnent
des leçons
ceux qui attaquent ce qui condamne ceux
qui quittent kg qui lui qui me regardait
de haut en plus il est entouré
d'intellectuels et pas n'importe quoi
des intérêts très importants
ces intellectuels rien il y en a pas un
seul qui a dit peut-être qu'on a commis
des erreurs c'est nous qui l'avons qui
l'avons influencé qui l'avons
conseillers qui auront qu'ils ont montré
une direction
vous en avez entendu a non seulement ça
mais vous ne trouvez pas un numéro du
journal le monde ou libération etc
sauf que ces gens là font des pétitions
pour nous dire tout ce qu'il faut penser
tout ce qu'il faut faire ou il faut
aller et avec une arrogance absolument
terrible c'est quand même saisissant
merci jean françois kahn d'avoir
participé à cette émission droit dans le
mur
c'est le titre de votre nouveau livre
qui vient de paraître aux éditions plon
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
et